what made him so good he was a chameleon
he he never made the same picture twice
War Kubrick did in in 1968 is he simply
refused to acknowledge that there were
any rules that he had to play by in
terms of of narrative when you go to the
theater and when you see them you're
completely surprised they make you look
at life a different way they make you
look at Being Human in a different way
they touch areas that you don't want
touch sometimes they carry with them
this idea that movies can do anything
and he'd ask me all the tough questions
what do you find interesting about that
story why do you want to make that
picture gee that sounds kind of boring
to me how can you make that interesting
I mean he was challenging me constantly
he gave me as much if not more than I
feel I ever ever could possibly give